today we're going to talk about self
suppress learning this is a lecture that
um that doesn't have a lot of math but
it's going to be all about very recent
works like probably like in the last
three or four years at the most so and
these are kind of like a pretty
interesting kind of intriguing kind of
like Concepts you know but nothing very
complicated everything is kind of simple
um
so so basically I think you know about
probably like 2013 2014 I think you know
deep learning new networks you know this
kind of ideas start to take off and and
we have this kind of kind of like a
revolution of AI in some sense like we
have a lot of amazing results in the
last about 10 years right after deep
learning took off
um but in the last two or three years I
think we see kind of like an emergent
new paradigm of AI which you know she's
still based on deep learning new
artworks but I think kind of like in
some sense um the kind of the paradigm
shift a little bit towards this kind of
like large-scale unsurprised learning or
self-spice learning so that's that's
kind of like what we're going to talk
about today so I guess uh um uh last few
lectures I think Chris talk about
Express learning so those are mostly
ideas you know like more classical ideas
like that was you know developed like
before deep learning took off and today
I think we're going to talk about the
kind of new type of five spice learning
you know which is not that different
from the old ones but uh you know with
new artworks and with some you know more
uh kind of like a um some kind of like
technical differences and and also like
some differences in the conceptual way
so um so I think um in some sense this
is called like a like a actually we also
write a white paper about this uh like a
bunch of extend for people like actually
there are 100 people more than 100
people on the paper so um mostly stand
for researchers stand for faculty and
students so rather right direct um we
wrote a white paper on this we call it
Foundation model
um so in some sense it's just a name so
um um it's a name for kind of this large
set of ideas that involves kind of like
pre-training online surprise data and
then kind of like use it for a bunch of
Downstream tasks I'm not sure whether
you know any of these passwords but
that's what I'm I'm here for so I'm
going to Define some of these words and
and tell you what's kind of the pipeline
and the Paradigm is
so basically
um uh kind of like the the main thing uh
for deep learning is that you know we
use like a new networks to face you know
larger data than we used to do before
like 10 years like 15 years ago and and
typically at the beginning when you use
deep learning you use it for uh surprise
learning right you have a lot of data uh
maybe a million data image night and you
have labels for them and then you pick
right work to predict the label and it
turns out that even audio network is
pretty big
um as until data is also somewhat big
you know like you can see good results
and sometimes you can even make it work
on small data
so but all of this requires you know
some amount of label data right so um
and then
um recently people figure out you know
maybe we should use unlabeled data as
well right so when you use unlabeled
data then you have you know much more
like for example for tax data I think
there's this data set which has like 40
trillion uh words in it
um so um but if you have label data sets
then you probably have a million labeled
documents you know and also label has
has specific meanings you know maybe you
need multiple labels for a documents
very many times so in many cases so if
you if you say I can tune with unlabeled
data then you certainly have
availability of a lot more data so I
think that's kind of like a uh uh the
kind of the main kind of the driving
force so now we are training on
unsurprised
um uh like on unlabeled data so and this
kind of fight so and how do you tune
with unsurprised unlabeled data I think
often um people have you know different
words for for the same kind of concept I
think one of the way to call it is
because self-surprise learning
so you supervise and as you'll see
you're going to supervise your model
with
um yourself your like the input itself
so so you don't have to use any label
and sometimes you know
um as I said you know in a white paper
we call this family of models called
Foundation model
um
Foundation
it's kind of like uh I will explain this
word a little more
um and some other bars words include
pre-training I'll explain
on them as well and adaptation
so I guess I will just
um
start by explaining pre-training so in
some sense the way that people do this
right now is the following so you have
this so-called pre-training stage where
you
um pre-tune
description
oh
so
large scale and here large scale really
means very very large scale and label
data set
it's not always the case that you have
to use unlabeled data set we'll see
actually in some cases you can use the
label data set for pre-tuning but you
really have to make a large scale
um and an unlabel is that is kind of
more common than uh the label data set
and also you push a large model
a very large model
and then this the second step is that
you somehow adapt this
so adapt this preachment model
to
some Downstream tasks
actually often you can download adapt to
my adoption tasks not only one
um so but the adaptation to 90 task is
the same as adapting to one you just do
it one by one so you adapt to some
Downstream tasks
um
tasks and these Downstream tasks are
often labeled data set so and for
Downstream tasks you know you have
different settings you know describe you
know in
more detail but generally you have you
know a few examples you know in a
downstream task uh for example you know
um
one example could be that you preach on
unlabeled text right that you can
download from internet right so you
could have like a chilling words you
know like documents uh like a lot of
documents with your children words
download from data from internet and you
preaching your model on this unlabel
data set uh how do you personally I'm
going to tell you and then after you get
this model this model is preachment you
know with no labels so you don't really
it doesn't really solve any particular
task and then you say I'm going to have
a downstream task about tax maybe I care
about sentiment analysis meaning you
care about whether this sentiment a
document or sentence is positive or not
right maybe for Amazon review where you
care about whether the reviews is
positive or not and then you say I'm
going to have
um you know a small number of examples
for sentiment analysis where I have I
have a small number of examples with
documents and label the positive or
negative label pair right so maybe like
a you know a hundred or a thousand kind
of like pairs of documents and label and
then that's called Downstream task and
then you want to adapt your prediction
model which is very general with generic
um to the specific task using some
additional kind of like tuning
so so that's the uh the general idea and
sometimes you know the down of course
you know kind of the distinction between
these two steps is that this time you
you may still involve some training some
kind of tuning in this adaptation step
because you're going to see the new
examples on a downstream task the
sentiment analysis does right and then
uh you have to kind of do something you
know with those examples so there is a
there's possible a training of
transition step in the adaptation uh
step as well but uh the difference here
is that this step often involves very
large scale data and this kind of
generic it's not like about task
specific uh learning so here is really
about task itself and also often times
you have much fewer data points uh than
the approach winning step you know
sometimes you have a thousand sometimes
you have ten thousands but generally not
by not a lot sometimes you can even work
with you know even zero uh examples in
adaptation step you can sometimes still
adapt to the task
so so kind of the intuition is that the
future new step is about you know
learning the generic structure or the
kind of like the intrinsic structure of
for example texts right or the for
example if you do it for image you are
learning the intrinsic kind of like
structure of the images maybe the kind
of the the intrinsic features about
images and then the adaptation step is
more about the task itself right so
um for images you can care about the
many different tasks you know maybe you
care about recognition maybe you care
about you know classification or maybe
you care about in a different kind of
like labels right so so you can have
labels of different granularities you
know a bunch of different tasks right so
this step is more about tasks
um
so
um so that's the kind of like the the
general kind of like intuition right you
approaching a lot of data so that's uh
give you the intrinsic structure or the
best intrinsic representations uh for
this kind of data and that
representations are useful for
Downstream tasks so that so that you
don't have to use like a a lot of
examples in Downstream tasks right
because you already learn some
interesting weapon stations that helps
you uh for the downstream task
um
right so so basically you know the kind
of the one implication here is that you
know you expect that this is uh this
this pipeline is going to do better for
than just preaching just training your
your model only on the downstream data
set so that's that's the the basic goal
right you have the Baseline is that the
trivial baselines that you you just
directly tune your model on the task
Downstream task
um but generally you don't have enough
data for that but if you do this kind of
like transfer
um it's transferring from the unlabeled
data set to this one then you may do
better
and and we call this kind of like
preaching model also Foundation model so
here I call it pushpin model right so
you can call also called Foundation
model and a reason for the word
foundation
I think the kind of like the implication
is that this uh this person model is
kind of like a
um a general model that you know general
purpose model that can do a lot of
different things
um and that's kind of the foundation and
this is the adaptation
that's a good question but I'll talk
about this yeah
okay any questions uh so far so I'm
going to tell you okay so this is
general idea I'm going to tell you some
kind of like uh I'm gonna you know start
with some simple notations and and tell
you how do people generally do this and
you're more kind of mathematical way
Okay so
so pretty training so
[Applause]
um so I guess
so let's say you have some data
something like X1
up to accent
so you have ended up points and and
could be very big and there is no label
here so this is unsurprised you know
pertaining of course sometimes you can
still have labels in it but let's say we
focus on a case where you have uh no
labels and you have a model
so let's specify the input and output of
the model so typical you can think of
this as you know the model let's say is
called V of theta and sometimes you feel
this as a feature extractor a feature
map
um but it's a learned feature map so
this is something that maps apps
to V of theta
if Theta of X and let's say visit of X
is some vector
so
and I guess you can as we have kind of
seen this kind of like we have this kind
of feature map often you call this
representation
features you know there are many many
names for it reference then
quotation
slash features
sometimes people also called embeddings
especially if you talk to more
mathematical people because in my field
this word embedding is used on in a
similar context
um so so this is a representation of the
of the raw that you have right so the
raw data could be text could be image
and this is a vector so this is
something we are familiar with right so
in both you know new artworks we have
like we have used the last but one layer
as the open station in a feature lecture
uh this is the the feature map although
like in a feature in the kernels or in
the kernel lecture we this is the
feature map but in a kernel lecture this
feature map is given uh and designed but
um later when we do the new artworks
this is the Learned feature map and here
we are still learning a feature map and
we are still learning a feature map
feature extractor whatever you call this
so and then but you but here you learn
this you know without um labels so you
say you have some protein loss maybe
some protein loss there are many forms
of positioning laws as well here I'm
just only giving one form something like
probably
nothing maybe some some laws
no um
like a sum of laws on single example
right so you can Define I'm going to
define the laws for different cases
um sometimes these laws can also depend
on multiple examples sometimes they can
depend on labels but something like this
you have operation loss
okay and then what you do is you just
optimize this loss
this IOP
um and let's say obtain
some say the heart
so so and I'm gonna call this my protein
model
or maybe that's called we can call it
Foundation model or something like that
okay so it's nothing
fancy so far yet I haven't told you what
the protein loss is
um there are many many different ways of
ways of doing pre-training I'm going to
tell you a few ways but so far it's just
you have some Define some loss function
but the loss only depends on the
unlabeled data and then you minimize the
loss and you get some
um
some model okay so and then I'm going to
do the adaptation step which I'm going
to be a little bit more concrete because
it's a little bit
easier
um so in adaptation is that
let's first clarify what kind of data
you have right before talking about how
do you do it so what data do you have so
you can also it's a down it's a it's a
label data set it's a label prediction
task the downstream tasks even though I
think you know if you look at enough
papers there are many other papers
talking about different type type of
tasks but here let's say we have some
labeled
um
on some prediction tasks and we have
some label data set so let's say we have
a few examples you know
let's call it X task one why task one
so and so forth
text task
and T
y task
s
and this is the number of you know down
Downstream examples
which is you know presumably much
smaller than
um
like I'm going to use NT
the num as the number of Downstream
so
um on this one you know this is is
supposed to be much smaller than the
number of unlabeled examples in a
perching step
so and they are actually a few different
settings you know so one setting is that
when NT is zero
so this is called zero shot
learning
so when T is zero it just means you
don't have anything you don't have the
data set so it's called zero shot
learning we will see how do you do it
you know sometimes you can still do zero
like you can still do the task without
even knowing anything about a task
um so and when NT is relatively small
I think uh this is called Fuel shots
and what do I mean by small I think in
the literature maybe five is typically
considered as small 5 10 20. um but
maybe not more than 50. if you have more
than 50 examples I think of course
there's no nobody really defined what
what exactly means but I think if it's
more than 50 examples
um per class in the downstream task I
don't think you you would call it few
shots so mostly like 10.
so um but of course you know there are
cases where you can have more examples
maybe like I think I've seen cases where
you have like 10 000 examples or maybe
even a hundred thousands in some extreme
cases so
um but the the end there typically could
be like a billion or even a trillion
sometimes 100 billion
so okay so how do okay so this is the
setup you know I'm giving this
information and then how do I uh do it
so a high level the first thing I'm
gonna do is I'm going to first Define
how do I even uh how do I adapt right so
I'm giving this model still your heart
so what's the what's the model to
predict a label I need to have a model
that protects the label so here the
Taylor hat
predicts a feature Vector but not the
label so so the first thing is that I'm
going to
um
typically I'm going to have a some kind
of like or maybe like me this one one
way to do this so This which is called
linear
um Pro
often people also cause linear hats
like a
um something like this so the kind of
like the the idea is you know you are
you probably should be familiar with
this
um it's just like you take this feature
fee say the height X
and then you apply a linear classifier
on top of it you say I'm going to take
an inner Paradox of this feature with
some linear class for doubling
and W transpose X is my prediction model
for the downstream task
um let's say suppose you have a
regression model then you just want this
number this to be some real number and
if you have classification then this is
supposed to predict the probability of
the label one of the label
so so it's just almost the same as what
we do in what works right you just you
have some feature and you apply some
linear height on this feature
so
so and then so it will do linear probe
what you do is that this is the
we have defined a prediction model
and then you can Define how to you can
say how do I learn this W right so here
no no that say the Hat here is fixed so
I'm only learning W when I'm doing a
linear probe so how do you learn W you
just say I'm gonna just tune w
um with some loss function with some
um
loss function
on the on the downstream examples so
basically I just do something like maybe
one over NT and minimize over w
and I have a loss function
which is the sum over the loss on the
downstream tasks assuming you have
Downstream tasks right if you assume you
have Downstream examples if you don't
have Downstream examples you have to
this doesn't apply anymore I'll tell you
how to do it we don't have Downstream
examples
um but suppose you have Downstream
examples then you just minimize the loss
something like the loss
that's called L task and this loss
function is something that compares the
label
and your prediction of your model the
prediction of your model is something
like this
right this task for example could be
just you know
L2 loss you know mean Square loss sorry
this this loss could be just the mean
Square loss or could be some kind of
cross entropy loss or some other loss
that you care about
and so when you do linear so-called
linear probe it means that you only
optimize W so you're only optimizing W
which is the vector of Dimension at
right so and is
W is in all right so you're just
optimizing this m-dimensional Vector to
make it to make your model
um fit on to the downstream task
um and this is the so-called adaptations
that basically the W is the thing that
you want to use to adapt your model to a
new task
any questions
so where the label come from you have
seen you have a label data somebody gave
you right so you collect the data set I
as as the same as what we did before but
the difference is that you don't you may
not have to collect as many as before I
I like if you just uh turn on this data
set just from scratch then you may need
more than what you do here
okay okay
um so I think
um so I guess maybe the questions what
what plans for learning you know come
into play here so I think you can in
some sense call this also transfer
learning so transfer learning used to be
the transport in this word you know
occurs you know like a um like this this
uh this term this term was used way
before people have done any of the pro
training so like uh so like now like I
think the like transferred on your
probably like people started like in
early 2000s or already even maybe before
that so and then at that time transfer
learning means what it means that
you know if I use protein language it
means that you preaching with a label
data set
and then you do some adaptation
so so so basically transfer learning
means this you know in the new language
so
um but now these days when we preaching
we push on unlabel data set
um and another maybe another thing is
that
um it used to be the case that um like
the like when transferring the the the
First Data that you turn on is also is
classification task which is kind of
like similar
so the the final task you care about
so but here
um in some sense the reason why people
introduce new terms for this is that
when you preach when this task could be
could be nothing like
um the downstream tasks I I haven't told
you what exactly the task is but as but
at least you can imagine there's not a
lot of similarity because here we don't
even have labels right it has to be
something different
um
yeah but but I think you can still say
this is transparent it's not like you
know there's no precise puncture between
this
oh
okay so let me introduce another way to
do um
um adaptation so another very common way
to do adaptation uh is that a so-called
fine-tuning
and it's also pretty easy to understand
so basically your model is the same
um but you just your model your
prediction
is some W transpose fee fatal effects so
here I write Theta but don't say the
hatch to indicate that I'm allowed to
change this data so here Theta doesn't
have to be exactly the preaching model
anymore it could be something
um that you can change so then what you
do is you say I'm gonna optimize
both
W and Theta
um on the downstream tasks
but if I just say this then this just
sounds like the standard surprise
learning right there's nothing different
from Super restaurant you are just
treating some new network right that
blue transpose V of say X on the
downstream task the difference from that
is that you optimize but you also
initialize
with
initialization
that Theta is initialized to be Theta
hat because I say the heart is the
prison model so basically you just as if
you are doing supers learning but Theta
is initialized to be Theta hat
and W there is nothing you can do with
that right because you didn't know W
before so w says something new so just
the initialize W to be random
so that's so called fine tuning and you
can optimize the same laws or whatever
laws you care about
a question
so Theta is the parameter for this V is
a function parametricized by Theta so
that's what
this week
no oh I think I just mean this is just
um
fee is just an uh is a name it's just
it's it's a fun you can call it a f
sub Theta this is an o h sub data it's
just a name for uh for this model that
is parametric respect Theta
so single fee says that is the new
network with parameters data
I just need a notation to indicate this
function right I can't just write status
Theta and Phi Theta you know they
corresponds to same thing but
mathematically I have to write V subset
of something to indicate that I'm
applying this model on x
so um you know I can give a blame for
let's say terminal is p but but it's not
um I didn't use it explicitly yet
foreign
have you come over
so
I haven't told you yet at all
um just because there are so many
different environments I have to somehow
do it in a top tongue fashion
um so so here for the downswing task I
can do it just because these two things
are very like a you can use this for
almost almost every situation but when
you talk about preach meaning I have to
talk about you know what you do in
computer vision what you're doing uh
language at least there's some
differences depending on the domain of
course there are also kind of recent
works that try to unify all of this
um but but at least I have to somewhat
um like talk about the domains
and that's what I'm going to talk about
next yeah
okay cool I guess uh maybe I'll just do
that so how do we approach right so
um so I'm gonna approach my reputation
how do I do that so let's first talk
about
um
um the the vision settings
so
um or more kind of like the the
classifications like the standard kind
of classification settings
so
so let's just uh you know for some
minutes I just think of like a vision so
so suppose you have some kind of like
images right so there are two types of
um pre-training so one type is called a
supervised per training
you may wonder you know why you know
like I already emphasized so much that
the preaching should be mostly on
unlabeled data but actually for vision
because you have a lot of label data all
right the imagenet is a pretty big data
set so you can actually do supervised
per training as well
um and this is just exactly what we have
seen before so you can just um what you
do is you just learn
a new network
um let's call this new artwork you know
maybe let's call it U transpose V of x
um
uh label data set say imagenet
so
um and here the notation is that this is
the um this is the last layer
of the new network
right the last layer was linear right
recall right so and Phi Theta of X is
the all the other layers right it's
basically the uh the the last
but one layer activation
right so so feature of X just denote you
know what you do in the first you know
uh R minus one layers and then U
transpose means the last layer of the
network
and so Theta of course so basically if
you have a new network like I don't know
whether this I think we discussed this
you know in one of the
um the lectures so
um in deep learning right so you haven't
watched work you have a lot of
connections you know and eventually
octopus and why and you review all of
this as your Phi of theta
and you view this as the so-called u and
sometimes people call this linear Health
right so you just do this you know this
is just exactly that's what we do
um
in the
um in the new network lecture and then
you just discard
then you just uh discard
uh you
and and just take
the fee Theta of X right the learned I
as the as the as the protein model
so you think of this as the feature and
this is a you think of this as a kind of
a universal feature in some sense and
the head is is special to the tasks you
use right to the to the label datas I
use right maybe use image nuts the Hat
has a thousands you know
um like classes you know
um that's that's something special but
the the features is something kind of
more Universal you just take the
features and and discard the hat and
then once you have a new task maybe not
image like maybe some other
classification task maybe let's say now
you have a new task which is Medical
Imaging right like you're detecting from
a scan image whether some person has
let's say cancer right so then you just
take this part this V Theta and then you
apply a new hat right I'm using W as the
new hat right you apply a new hat and
then you fine tune all
um just a linear Probe on your
Downstream task right so so you remove
this hat and I apply something else and
then you do some tuning on the
downstream task
um so that's uh that's the supervised
project
if you're like uh the medical images are
like a different size than like the ones
that it was preaching on
um what kind of like stuff do we need to
do to make it work yeah I think
typically if the size are different you
just have to upside of it I'm assuming
maybe in medical unit is lower
resolution you just have to
do something
opposite right you just make the size
bigger I think you can pack some either
you can pass them zeros outside or you
can just um maybe wrap technique
Subway
there's nothing fancy uh also you
mentioned earlier that like if the class
the task isn't similar it might not work
as well so like is that a concern here
so
um
so here at least
you'll have to consider much because
because of that because
um CR let's say the proton images you
know they have the image night classes
they are all like uh like sometimes
animals you know all kind of like common
objects right
um but the only way you discard the Hat
you remove the hat and then you add a
new hat you know maybe now your new
tasks just have two labels right cancer
or not right
um and and you just apply to that
um but so in terms of the matter you can
at least you can apply it when the task
labels are different
um but whether it will work you know
sometimes depends on how how different
your new task is from the old task so
typically if you use an image sniper
training you always learn something
reasonable about the features
um you wouldn't be terrible but you know
but if your task for example your
Downstream task is really not even
common images nothing like that's just
some kind of like a random images then
probably it wouldn't help that much
Okay so
so here there's nothing really um that
um let's fancy and people kind of like
there's other ways like in the beginning
of the uh the Deep learning uh era
um and there are some other kind of like
and the second one I'm going to talk
about is uh the so-called uh contrastive
learning which is now unlabeled
um unlabeled uh like a unsurprised
learning algorithm for pro training or
some other people call it self-su
questioning so so contrastive learning
so now I don't have any labels I just um
have unlabeled inside I need to Define
loss function on unlabeled data sets so
how do I do that
um so I need to first introduce a notion
called Data augmentation
this
so a data augmentation is um something
that as the name suggests you are
augmenting one example into uh a
artificial example that still makes some
sense so and typically for images what
you do is you just say uh I have a
original image
and then you augment
um by doing some kind of like so-called
run you can do a few things maybe a
random crop
to crop us a a patch of image as a new
image or you can apply a random crop
plus a flip you can flip the image you
know just with the mirror flip and or
you can do some color transformation
color transformation means that maybe
you make the image darker you know
brighter or sometimes you can just even
do weird more weird kind of like color
transformation you change although the
the brown color to the white color you
know like you can do some kind of like
changing of the color scheme
and there are many others you know um
you know some of them are more advanced
and sometimes you can even learn the
transformation but these are kind of the
common ones so basically given an image
you can do this random operations kind
of like you can try to choose to flip or
not that's a random decision you can
choose to crop which part of the image
like you can do some kind of like random
color transformation so you have some
Randomness here and then give an image X
basically you can generate a random
augmentation that's called X hat
and if you do if you do this again you
can generate another one which can be
which I'm going to call X tilde
and if you do it more and more times you
can join even more of these
augmentations
so these augmentation is used in
Surprise learning actually as well uh we
didn't discuss them just because they
are low level details for super
certainly what you actually do is that
you can give an image and the label you
can generate the augmentation and then
just assume the augmentation is your new
image
so um so you just replaced all the image
by the augmentation and and every time
you do this you know with a new
augmentation like like every time you
see this or this image you you replace
the image by a new augmentation and and
tune with that argument images
and that seems to improve the uh in some
sense you make the data set bigger in
some sense because
these are you know every time you
augment right you're gonna get a
different image in some sense even
though they are something similar but
still you make an effective size of that
side a little bit bigger
um so um so that's why people use it in
um
um uh in Surprise learning but now I'm
going to use it in honest questioning
um I actually now people call it
self-suppressed learning so I'm going to
use this to create some kind of
supervision uh or create some kind of
Express logs what you do is you say I'm
going to call this
X hat first of all I'm going to Define
some notation this is called a positive
pair
so so positive pairs are augmentations
of the same image
so one um you can imagine you know one
property of the positive pair is that
these two images two augmented images
are probably should be somewhat similar
semantically even though they may not
have the same color scheme they may not
have exactly the same orientation or the
right so they are still somewhat similar
right so so what you do is you say uh
you are gonna
um try to make
um so you you're going to design loss
functions such that one you want to make
a fee of theta of X hat
and
Phi of theta
X tilde
um
close
so basically you say I have two
augmentations one is x height and the
other is X tilde
um you want the these two augmentations
to have
um similar uh representations
in the including space
so that's one goal of the loss I'm going
to tell you exactly what the loss looks
like but this is one goal of the loss
but if you just have this goal you can
see that this loss function is a little
bit unquestionable in some sense because
maybe you should just map every image to
the same point then everything has
exactly the same representation then you
satisfy this this goal right so so it's
ideal that you should have something to
counter balance to avoid you to just
collapse everything into one one thing
so how do counterbalance the way your
counter balance is that you
um just to say
um you want random images to have
different representations so
let's erase something here
which one I should use here
so basically to counterbalance this
you
the second goal is that you want suppose
you say I'm going to have some two
random example
let's say you have um maybe X and Z so
maybe a cat and dog right and then you
augment X into X hat as the same way
here and then you argument Z to Z hat
so because x and z you know are two
different images maybe one is cloud on
the other stock so the argumentation is
probably looks very different as well
and the augmentations are semantically
very different
so then your second goal is to make
uh V Theta X hat
and
V Theta
Z hat
the augmentations of two different
examples are far away
so this is the to counter balance to
avoid you to collect everything to the
same point
and actually there's a name for this
pair it's X hat Z hat is also called uh
either random pair
or negative pair
so
um at the very beginning I think people
you call it negative pair which is not
exactly right in the sense that
x and z are just random choice of two
images
there's no guarantee that they are
exactly they don't have exactly the same
they don't have the uh the same class or
same kind of like meaning right there is
some small chance that both x and z are
both from the same class right even you
have like a following classes there's
still a little bit chance that x and z
are from the same class but in most of
the cases x and z are from different
classes
um and and they are semantically
different so Random pair might be a
little bit more accurate but negative
pair is is what people call it at the
beginning and I think now people just
use this inter-exchangeably
so um so basically you want to write
random pairs to have different
representations and you want positive
pairs to have similar representations
so
um so this is the design principle how
do you do this exactly so um there are
multiple papers they are kind of like a
at least four or five papers that use
this kind of like a principle
um and sometimes actually uh some papers
actually just even drop the number two
you just use one and somehow still
sometimes it works just because there's
some other kind of like counter balance
in in a system that can kind of achieve
too without explicitly encouraging it
but let's now talk about those let's
talk about one case where the simplest
case we have both one two especially
encode it in a loss function which is
called Sim clear and this is I think
basically the first
um first paper that makes this kind of
Ideal work
um
so how do you exactly encode these two
kind of principle so it seem clear what
people do is the following
so what you do is you say you first take
a batch of example
a random batch of example like in SGD
let's call this example X1
up to xB
so FB example
and then you first do some augmentations
so your augment
to
um X hat one
up to X Hat B
and X tilde one
up to X tilde B
as as you can see these two are the
augmentations of the first example these
two are the augmentations of the second
example and these two are the
augmentations of the the B's example
and then here is the loss function
so
let me write down the loss function and
then I can explain
so
so the intuition is that you want to
design loss functions that basically
maybe maybe let's see so
oh I don't have a different color today
so because these two are augmentation of
the same example you want them to be to
have similar representations
right and maybe the same thing happens
for these two right so any any pairs you
should have similar applications but if
you look at this one and this one
suppose you pick something like this
then you want them to have different
rapid stations
and what you do is that you make the
loss function
the loss function is equal to this
this is another button
complicated and the first set but it's
actually not that hard
um
so I guess
so here the indices is the most
important thing so this is I this is I
this is I this is I
and here this is J
sorry my handwriting is a little bit
unclear so okay so
maybe the first thing to realize is the
following so
um maybe let's focus on this term
maybe let's call this term a and this
term B
realize that this is also a
right so just a little
the same term so this is really
something like a lot minus log a over a
plus b something like this absolutely
speaking
so and and if you do some simple math
you'll see that this one is
uh
decreasing
in a
an increasing
in b
um this is uh relatively easy I guess
you can either take a derivative or just
at least the increasing in B is pretty
easy because this function is this
function is decreasing in B and log is a
monotone function and you have a minus
in front and for a is the the reverse
Direction
so
um that means that
if you minimize this log function you
are trying to encourage the term a to be
smaller because it's decreasing a right
sorry you want the term a bigger because
the loss function is decreasing a the
bigger the a is the smaller the loss
function is
so you want this a term which is this
inner product between
actually a term is exponential of inner
product but so you want a which is equal
to exponential
X hat I
transpose V Theta X tilde I
to be
um this U1 is to be big
topic
right you want this to be big that means
that you want this representation of the
X hat I and the representation of the X
tilde I to be as close to each other as
possible you want your inner product to
be big
right that fulfills our first goal where
we want the representation of two
examples the augmentation of the the
representation of the augmentation of
the same example to be as close as
possible that's the kind of the first
goal
and and then you want this B term
to be
uh to be small right because the
function is increasing B and you are
minimizing the function right the bigger
the function B is the smaller uh oh
sorry the the function is increasing B
right and you want the function to be
small so you want a b to be also small
right the smaller the B is the smaller
the function is right if you want these
two to be small and what are the terms
in B basically you have this kind of
term
foreign
where you have I and J here
right so basically you want to say that
for different when it's the augmentation
this is augmentation of the I example
this is augmentation of the JS example
so their augmentations should have
um or should be small so so they're
they're in a paradox should be small so
that means that the representation
should be
um far away uh from each other
any questions
sure also how um
exponential is an increasing power if
you want to experience yourself actually
smaller then it means you want an
argument of the exponential
the first one is straight so J only
shows up once all the others are I
so there are other interpretations of
this loss function it was
um I'm not sure what they are they are
easier to understand or be harder to
understand than this you know one
interpretation of this loss function is
that
you can view this as a multi-class
classification kind of like questions so
you are trying to distinguish
so basically in some sense you are you
can supposed to do a lot of math you can
see that this is kind of the same laws
as
uh as the following hypothetical
question so the question is like given
this data set I want to say given for
example X hat
I the I think that the first
augmentation of the ielt example I want
to distinguish which one
is uh is is the positive pair and which
one is negative pair so basically let's
say
suppose you are this is another
interpretation which I I personally
think is harder to understand
um but uh
but let me just anyway say it so suppose
you have some example x height I and you
have the corresponding X tilde I so you
can kind of view this else as you want
to
given this x height I you want to test
which one of this these three examples
are uh the most correlated with I in
some sense
uh and I and you want the x height I
this one to to stand out in some sense
uh compared to the other correlation you
want the correlation between these two
to be dominating all the others so that
you can kind of say this one is my my
body in some sense it's my it's the it's
the it's the the other example in the
pair
um yeah so
um but anyway you know the the exact
form of the loss function is not that
important right so there are there are
actually other ways to implement this
it's not like it's really necessarily
have to use this loss function the
principle is probably more important
than the loss function
right so
cool
so
I guess just to summarize this is a loss
function that only depends on X right so
you didn't use anything about label
or self-supervised uh loss function so
it sells price because you self-surprise
just means you don't use any supervision
except some part of your yourself
um
okay any other questions
oh
we are fighting in this case we are the
specification like because I wish images
feature the feature the rapid stations
the the function that computes the
representation is the feature extractor
or the
um something like that it makes sense
of ultimate blaster
that's why I have to transports
Okay so
[Applause]
okay so the next thing I'm going to talk
about is how do you do page training
when you have language
um and there I'm also I'm going I'm
going to tell you one method
um uh which is also like a self
surprised or unsurprised per tuning um
but the method is a little bit different
so
Okay so
this is
basically discard the very last layer so
and use the walls remaining Network to
perform like all the possible damage
causing the future oh no there's no
there's no last layer anymore here right
like this field is a is a new network
like like this field setup is kind of
like uh something right for start from X
you know a lot of neurons they draw a
lot of your arches something like this
right and eventually you also put some
embeddings this is free oxide
and and that's it that's that's your
representation
um so you don't have to be scarves but
you have to add the last layer when you
do the classification
drawing is a little bit too flushed
cool so
Okay so
um large language models
so the first thing I need to address is
that how do I encode the data right so I
have for some text where they are
discrete words I need to first turn them
into numerical numbers
um I guess you know if you remember I
think uh uh a few weeks back right so we
talked about this event
uh model right this model that you
include data by this very simple binary
Vector right every every document is
encoded as a as a zero one vector of
some size so so those are you know very
simple uh so today we're we're gonna do
the the more realistic one so you just
and but but the encoding becomes easier
actually just because um what you do is
you just directly encode each Vector
um each word uh I I it's just the the
display token so okay let me just say
this um so so I'm saying that this is um
this is a way to encode but the encoding
is kind of like a
um to some extent much conceptually much
simpler so basically the first thing is
that let's define what is an example
where you have a we have like language
so typically I think you know for me the
best way to think about think about the
example in language is that you think of
as as a document or something like that
no a sequence of words because you
cannot view every word as example then
you lose the the examples are supposed
to be somewhat kind of like independent
with each others right so if you use if
you use your word as an example there's
too small for granularity so you view
each document as example
um so that's kind of the mental picture
I think of so you have a sequence of
word maybe X1 up to XT
and and this is a one example in reality
what people do is that people don't
really kind of like just literally look
at which you know the the exam the the
documents because what you are given is
that you are given for example all the
Wikipedia text on on Wikipedia and this
is a gigantic file which is really just
a sequence of words and everything is
concussion together and then what people
do is that you just truncate uh you just
take a consecutive kind of sequence of
like Words as one example maybe you take
something like you know maybe 500 Words
consecutive 500 words or maybe a
thousand words as one example but so but
the only case you know
um I think you know you know if you
don't care about the details you know
implementation details it's just fine to
think of each example as a kind of a
document an important thing is that it's
a sequence of words
and and there's another small detail in
the implementation so
um when you really do this you know you
sometimes you don't really operate on a
granularity of words right for example
one possible choice you can operate on
the granularity of characters right you
view each character as One X I uh people
don't really do that people what people
do is that people are operating on the
the level called tokens and each token
typically these days in the best model
each token is kind of like a word but
sometimes smaller than a word so
basically you can think of like most of
the common tokens uh oh sorry what most
of the common words are a single token
like the the top
I think I think last time I checked this
it's kind of like that the first like
20K
frequent words
are are all just a single token by
themselves but sometimes you have longer
words that just never show up very often
and then you break them in some way into
uh into two tokens right so a very very
long word might be two tokens
um this is just another small detail
just in case you are implementing
anything like this but you know for
conceptually you just think of each word
as a single x i here and you have a
sequence of words keywords here that's
one example
so and then what you do is that you say
and if let's say suppose you know you
have a vocabulary so each word is uh in
some like sex
one two V so you have like V possible
words
um and each talk uh each uh example is a
sequence of words
and
when you say language model
basically people always refers to
a probabilistic model
probabilistic
four P of the joint probability
in some sense this is kind of like the
same kind of like modeling
methodology as with what we do with
mixture of gaussians right you're
modeling The Joint probability of your
data of your ex
but if you just directly model the
probability this joint probability is
kind of very difficult because this one
has support
this one has support
size
is distribution right so like how many
possible sentences you can have here you
can have uh support size is something
like V to the T because each word can
have t v choices and you have t words so
this is really exponentially large uh
family of possible sentences and and if
you model this distribution it's kind of
challenging
so what people do is that people do is
use chain rule
so you say
this challenge probability can be
written as P of X1 times P of X2 given
X1 times P of x3 times X1 X2
up to P of x t given X1 up to x t minus
1.
and then you model
on
each of these p x t Little T given X1 up
to x t minus 1. you model this
conditional probability uh this
conditional probability
using some parametric form and then you
learn that parameters
and the the good thing about this
conditional probability is that now you
only require the one the problem is one
word right that's the problem of that
one word uh is of size V right so like
sorry the the support of this
probability right so like the number of
choices words here is V so instead of V
to the power t
okay so nice question is how do you
model this how do you build a parameters
form for this conditional probability
so
I'm not going to tell you exactly how
you do it if I generally you just do it
with your network I'm going to tell you
you know there's some kind of details
I'm omitting here but roughly speaking
what you do is the following
so
um so first the first thing you do you
have to do an embedding
followers
meaning for every word Acts
you embed this maybe for whatever word I
this is a word I
you invite this word into a vector e i
and this Vector e i let's say is in
dimension d
so every word will correspond to a
vector so you're going to have V vectors
each Vector corresponds to word
and and these vectors will be learned so
these are parameters of our system
so so so so after so these are the
parameters and then
um after I have these parameters and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
um after I have this embeddings I'm
going to
put these embeddings into a gigantic
image work and let them let the new
artwork to output on the conditional
probability in some sense so basically
roughly speaking
here you're gonna have
some model which I kind of view as a
black box these days people call this
you use something called Transformer I'm
not going to tell you exactly what
Transformer do that's because it's
actually pretty complicated and and it's
kind of out of the scope of this course
um you know if you you can take a look
at PayPal or take some other Advanced
courses but you know for for the first
other concept concept this is a black
box right action many many people don't
have to up many people who use the
Transformer don't have to open up the
black box so so that's why I'm only
telling you what's the what's the input
and output of this black box
so but this is a new network this is a
kind of like complex Network
and the the way to use this black box is
the following so you just say I have
some sequence of words right X1 up to x
t
I'm going to first encode them by the
word embedding I'm going to have e of X1
up to e of x t
so e sub x t
so these are vectors
and this Transformer takes in the
sequence of vectors
and then output you a sequence of
vectors
so so the output let's call them C1
I think let's call it I call it C2 C3 up
to CT plus one
so
um and let's also just uh give a name
for this Transformer like let's call
this function V Theta so
so this function V Theta after given
um out of the input embeddings it
outputs a sequence of vectors each of
these Vector let's say is still of
Dimension D even though this Dimension D
you know in reality this D might be the
different D from this but they are
vectors
okay so after you get these vectors then
uh you can use these vectors to compute
the conditional probability that you the
the you use these vectors to predict
conditional probability
so basically you say that I have this
let's do this I guess just
so now after you got these vectors C1 up
to CT
so I'm going to use
C
T
to predict
P of x t given X1
up to x t minus 1.
okay
so what I do here is the following so
what I want to predict is uh is this
thing right so
this is actually this probability
distribution is about in sometimes it's
a vector right it's a vector of
Dimension V because to describe this
proper distribution you have to describe
P of x t is equal to one the first word
give me x what up to x t minus one
up to P of x t is equal to V given X1 up
to x t minus 1.
right so to model this probability you
have to model kind of predict V numbers
and these V numbers is supposed to be
sum up to one
and how do you do this this is kind of
like you know multi-class classification
um like uh so what you do is you
basically you say I'm gonna have a soft
Max
of sun
uh WT
times the vector CT so let me specify
here so c t is a vector of Dimension d
and WT is additional parameter uh this
is a parameter
that you will learn so this WT is of
dimension
um
V by D
so basically WT times CT will be
Dimension V so you have like multiple so
for every possible choice you get a
vector right and then you apply a soft
Max to make them probability so this
whole thing will be
in dimension V
so in some sense this WT times c t is
just the logits and then you apply a
soft Max to turn them into probability
and that's your prediction for this uh
for this problem so in some sense you
just view each word as a class right you
have V classes and how do you predict uh
um something with how do you do a
classification with v classes what you
do is you first use a linear this is a
linear hatch on top of the city and then
you do a soft Max to turn them into
probability
um so
I think the definition of soft Max I
think we probably defined this in one of
the early lectures right so let me just
Define it again so
I should use this problem
So Soft Max is just like if you have
soft Max
Alpha Vector U is really
uh something like this exponential U1
over sum of exponential UI
and then exponential
U
so V over sum of exponential
UI something like this
right so you turn on the logits U into a
probability Vector which sum up to one
any questions
[Music]
so I'm going to use C2 to predict X2 oh
I'm going to see it you know it's a it's
a in you can index in any way I I chose
this is to indicate that C2 is to use to
is used to predict X2 given as well
so and actually there's one thing I
didn't tell you which is actually
important so
when you predict this probability
uh this probability right this is my
model to predict the probability right
I need to insist that
I haven't seen other words
like I I have to insist that I only have
seen X1 up to x t minus one right if I
have seen x t already I can just output
X the true value of x t I've seen right
so
um so so actually this Transformer uh
there are multiple versions of
Transformer the Transformer here I'm
talking about you know on the term is
called Auto regressive
Transformer is this is just a name what
I mean is that
you you you design this Transformer in a
way so that City only
depends
on
X1
up to x t minus one
so Define you design this architecture
such that you have this property such
that the city Only depends on X1 up to x
t minus one so that when you predict x t
you are not going to be able to see any
other words after x t so that's why you
have a you have a proper definition of
the probabilistic model
um but but this is like a just think of
this as given the Transformers internal
property ensures you to have this right
how do you connect all of the neurons by
ensures this property
inside
so this the in many of the dimensions uh
I call it d right now
um but the dimension is just a parameter
you can you can change you can change it
to anything of course it has to be some
or large something like maybe a third
and something like that
I understand
yeah
how do we do we have to create as many
uh
that's a good question right so if you
use one hot Vector probably you should
use embedding of Dimension V right
because you have V choices but now I
think the embedding Dimension is often
smaller than a vocabulary size I think
the vocabulary people typically use is
something on about 40K maybe 60 60k
something like that
um
something on that level
um but the dimension
the dimension is probably a thousand
only
Matrix you mean the the mapping from the
I to the e i
um it's not a it's not uh uh it's
learned
so so basically you just learn this so
so you have
E1 up to EV right each word has a vector
and you concussing them all optimize The
Matrix and you view this as a parameter
of your this is part of the parameters
of your training
okay so now the final step is just that
after you already Define the prediction
you have to Define loss function to
learn the parameters right the
parameters are the question was great
like the parameters include
E1 up to EV also include WT
right and and that's it right that's all
also the parameters in the Transformer
which I didn't specify that's a new
network which is viewed as Black Box so
and now you learn you take a loss
function
right which contains all the W's which
is a function of W's the Theta and the
Eis
the E the e
and then under what this loss function
is just the cross entropy loss
of all the positions so cross
entropy laws
of all precision
of position I
and and if you really think about what's
the cross entropy loss for the for the
soft Max for this kind of things is
really just this
um
but but you do necessarily have to
really exactly see why is this but it's
really just the minus log probability
uh of pt
and x t
um
so if you call this thing PT
suppose we call this PT
then basically the X teeth entry a minus
log p x t actually is
this is the axis entry of that Vector PT
and and this is just the the the the
cross-centric Plus
but don't worry if you don't got this
line it's really just a empirical you
just have to when you implement this you
just have to call the cross-centric
below sync and give it to it
um
running a little bit late uh any
questions
nothing I didn't
I cheated a little bit
so here I'm taking
so this definition I can only Define H
for T is two in some sense I don't have
a production model for X Y
I only have the prediction for X2 given
X1 X3 given X2 I didn't have a
probabilistic model for X1 in priority
just people just forgot about it just
don't use it you know it doesn't matter
that much you know you can try to fix it
to make a principle but I don't think it
matters that much anyway so just because
you you have so many problems like a
public probability test model and if you
ignore one of them it's not a big deal
um Okay so
now let me talk about uh how to adapt
um how to adapt uh this language model
to to Downstream tasks so I I've erased
the fine tune and the linear probe but
uh if you can still do those those are
very general though you can use those
function and linear probe for almost
anything so and for this kind of like
language model the way you do find
tuning in probe is just that you
on
it's it's just the only thing you have
to decide is that which
output you should use as the
representation of this documents so you
have so many outputs here and you which
one you take is the representation of
this sentence so you just take c one
option is you take CT as the
representation
and then you add some hat W and your W
transpose this is your prediction model
for Downstream tasks or task
and then you can choose to only fine
tune W or you can choose to fine tune W
and the parameters that that you use to
compute CT right the parameters used to
compute CTR those parameters in the
Transformers those Eis those embeddings
so so that's easy and and just because
it's generic and for language models the
interesting thing is that you can also
undo this uh with uh um some other ways
where you can do adaptation with other
ways so one way to do this is so-called
the zero shot
uh learning
and here is it's just very easy so
basically whatever task you have you
just turn it into some questions or some
kind of like closed test
um like you have a blank to fill in and
then you just give it to the to the
model and then the model to generate the
next word so basically what I'm saying
is that you just say for example suppose
you just turn you can have X
which is just the
you know this model can take in your
sequence forward right you just say
maybe is
the speed of light
suppose you care about the speed of
light is constantinal note
and you just turn it into a question
right you call this you call this um
this is X1 X2 X3 up to XT
and then because this model can generate
maybe let's say this is x t minus one
and then you use this model to generate
x t because this model can do
conditional generation right you can
given X1 up to x t minus one you can
generate x t and give maximum after x t
you can generate x t plus one you can
just keep generating the uh the tokens
you know afterwards and you just put
this into the model and let it generate
and if you generate the next word is no
or yes then you get the answer
and maybe sometimes it generates
something slightly different from just
yes or no then you have to pass the
answer in some way but you just write
the model to generate the answer that's
not that's that's one way
and so basically you are using the
generation power of this model that's
probably the important thing right
because giving this mod so basically
here the important thing is that the way
you have this model makes it that given
some sequence of words you can generate
the next token and then you can feedback
this new token to the to the system to
generate another one and you can keep
generous so so so so so that's why this
gives us opportunities to have other
adaptation method which based on
generation and another kind of like a
even more intriguing way to to uh to
adapt is the following is called in
context learning
so the in context learning
so here you are dealing with you know
a so-called fuel shot cases
so you have a few examples
so suppose you um and let me just give
an example to there are so many
flexibilities I'll just show one example
so what you do is you just concatenate
all your examples into a so-called
prompt
concatenate
examples
into uh
in something into into
actually in the language of this lecture
we call it document right but but in the
if you look the paper is called prompt
so what I mean it just means you you can
correct all of this into a sequence uh
for example suppose you care about you
know learning how to add up two numbers
suppose you have a question Q which is
something two
three is what
and then you do have a you do have a
you have some examples right you say you
know that this is five so this is your X
task one
and this is your white task one
so you're just concaten them into a into
a sequence of tokens
so like this and then you just keep
concatenating
and you say Q
six plus seven no no plus I choose do
not use plus because I want to make it
difficult right so something like this
you're trying to learn what this symbol
means right so and then this is X task
2 and Y and then you're Contracting the
Y times two
so you say answer is 13. and now suppose
you just have two examples and you want
to learn and now your question is
this symbol 2 is equals to what
so you can cut in all of this together
and you call this X1 up to x t
and you give this X1 after x t the
sequence of all the symbols to the model
and let it generate and then you ask
this sequence to generate our XT plus
one
so use this to generate x t plus one
right or maybe even XT plus two so and
so forth
and and it turns out that if you give
these things to the model and they will
generate something reasonable for you so
we will generate something for example
for this case it will generate a
17. and then you got answer the answer
is 70.
so and you see that this is sometimes
says that you learn the downstream tasks
you'll learn that this symbol means
addition
from this
um I'm not sure whether this is a little
abstract but I think what I can do is
the following so I think I'm this is
about time and we can stop
um like we can stop the class and but I
can show you some uh uh some examples
you know just the live